[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
sur TV 78 pour le 7 8 votre émission
pour bien démarrer la soirée actualité
Infopratique idée de sortie au menu
comme d'habitude voici le sommaire de ce
mercredi 3 mai
bien qu'elle soit promulguée la réforme
des retraites continues de susciter des
oppositions des parlementaires de gauche
et du centre ont déposé une deuxième
demande pour l'organisation et d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée pour
revenir à l'âge légal à 62 ans le
Conseil constitutionnel doit se
prononcer aujourd'hui après un premier
rejet en avril et nous en parlons avec
Benjamin Lucas député nups de la 8ème
circonscription des Yvelines il
s'agirait de la première cause de
mortalité chez les enfants de 1 à 4 ans
les accidents de la vie courante font de
nombreuses victimes chaque année à
plaisir des ateliers de prévention au
gestes qui sauve s'adresse aux parents
et aux enfants ils sont assurés par une
infirmière spécialisée en accompagnement
périnatale Déborah Agnès enfin comme
chaque mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma
les films à ne pas manquer le dernier né
des studios Marvel une comédie et un
drame français notre journaliste Céline
Charles vous livrera sa sélection et
puis il y aura aussi le coup de cœur de
notre pro evilinois pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir un long métrage
du sport également au menu de ce 7 8
avec nos deux invités de part et d'autre
de la table il s'agit de Tiphaine charol
bonsoir et d'Alexandre Verrien bonsoir
du Rugby Club de Versailles Tiphaine
Charles vous êtes le manager de l'équipe
première senior Alexandre verlien vous
êtes joueur de l'équipe Versailles qui
vient d'être éliminé au barrage de
fédéral 2 une défaite face au Creusot
27.6 dimanche dernier fin de saison donc
pour le club qui vivait sa première en
plus dans le championnat de fédéral 2
une place une sixième place obtenue au
terme de la saison régulière dans le
championnat de fédéral 2 on va revenir
justement avec vous sur ce dernier match
sur la saison aussi plus globalement du
Rugby Club de Versailles un mot pour
qualifier la saison pour commencer
est-ce que vous en avez ainsi vous
deviez définir la saison en un mot qui
fait une charol c'est encore une saison
bien accomplie avec des objectifs qui
ont été amplement remplis donc
effectivement voilà elle s'arrête
aujourd'hui au barrage mais voilà tout
le monde est content de la saison qu'on
a passé que ça soit le club les joueurs
l'encadrement les bénévoles donc tout va
bien au RCV bilan plutôt positif en un
mot si on essaye de résumer la saison du
Rugby Club de Versailles même deux allez
je vous en acte 2 Alexandre pour nous on
pense que elle a été réussite exactement
parce que là-bas c'était sur un maintien
qu'on jouait maintenant on est on a
réussi à se qualifier pour les
fascinants et sur une première année
Fédérale 2 donc très très correct on
reviendra plus largement sur cette
saison est dû Rugby Club de Versailles
dans le championnat de Fédérale 2 dans
cette semaine assez courte avec le pont
du 8 mai en vue on va aussi se projeter
sur la semaine prochaine avec cet
événement qui sent bon l'été le Paris
bear festival revient pour une dixième
édition du 8 au 14 mai on en parle avec
Sébastien Rousset qui est avec moi avec
nous également plateau bonsoir vous êtes
cogérant dos cloque brawling qui est une
brasserie artisanale installée à
Bois-d'Arcy vous serez présent justement
pour le final de l'événement Paris bear
festival les 13 et 14 mai aux grandes
contrôles à Paris le Paris bear festival
c'est le rendez-vous dédié à la bière
artisanale à consommer bien sûr on le
rappelle avec modération ils mettent en
valeur notamment la scène brassicole en
Île-de-France est-ce que l'Île-de-France
est un territoire riche en matière de
bière artisanale de France est devenu un
territoire riche voire même très riche
en matière de bière artisanale
on est dans une région où il y a encore
des projets de brasserie en cours donc
il y a encore un bel avenir pour la pour
la brasserie artisanale francilienne et
l'événement qui est le pari de bière
festival c'est une bonne manière de
lancer de lancer tous mouvements autour
de la bérartisanale en région parisienne
et c'est aussi une très belle manière de
parler de la bière artisanale en règle
générale puisqu'il y a des brasseries de
toute la France et voire même du monde
entier qui seront présentes sur
l'événement donc c'est c'est une belle
fête donc 10e édition qui a lieu la
semaine prochaine on aura l'occasion
d'en parler avec vous tout à l'heure
également Régine rage de la rédaction de
TV 78 avec mon plateau bonsoir Régine à
suivre avec vous dans un instant les
informations du jour à retenir de ce
mercredi 3 mai dans les Yvelines dans
cette édition également nous prendrons
la direction de l'Allemagne pour la
suite du projet européen JIRA auquel est
associé la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines on vous dit tout dans un
instant je mets également surnaturel
aventure un rallye 100% féminin et
électrique tout cela bien sûr après
avoir jeté un coup d'œil aux prévisions
météo de demain
éclairci et température assez douce dans
la matinée dans les Yvelines vous le
voyez même condition annoncée sur
l'ensemble du territoire avec une
température de 13 degrés le matin dans
l'après-midi peut ou pas d'évolution
prévoyait toujours quelques éclaircies
côté thermomètre 22 degrés sont annoncés
sur les secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles ou dans et Rambouillet ce
jeudi 4 mai c'est la Saint Sylvain le
point à présent sur l'actualité du jour
dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence avec le chiffre du jour
Régine plus de 1000 trottinettes 350
vélos électriques ont été déployés dans
l'intercommunalité de Grand Paris
senewaza oui Grégory et c'est hier que
le lancement a eu lieu après
l'interdiction des trottinettes en
libre-service à Paris il y a un mois ce
service de location et déployé par
l'opérateur tiers mobility dans cette
ville des Yvelines manque la jolie
manque la ville Les Mureaux melant en
Yvelines artricourt Poissy et carrière
sous Poissy
quels sont les tarifs justement alors il
faudra compter 1 euro pour débloquer la
trottinette ou le vélo électrique il
faudra compter également 20 centimes la
minute pour la location de la
trottinette et 23 centimes pour un vélo
électrique l'opérateur propose également
des forfaits des tarifs spécifiques
solidarités et étudiants toujours en
matière de mobilité le réseau de bus se
réorganise sur les bassins de Poissy
Verneuil-sur-Seine et aux Mureaux et les
lignes vont faire peau neuve et ce à
partir du 9 mai
Île de France mobilité a pour objectif
de les rendre plus accessibles et facile
à comprendre la première modification se
porte sur la numérotation des lignes les
doublons seront supprimés pour permettre
à chaque usager de mieux se repérer et
enfin de nouveaux itinéraires seront
proposés la future ligne une par exemple
donnera un accès direct à la gare de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye depuis carrière
sous Poissy ça a été officialisé
aujourd'hui à 50 ans en Yvelines la
première édition du festival électro
thrison n'aura pas lieu et oui cet
événement écolo est inclusif était
initialement prévus cet été à la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le
but était d'attirer 20.000 festivaliers
avec à l'affiche une majorité d'artistes
féminines transgenre et non binaire le
festival avait reçu le soutien de
l'agglomération de trappes et de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux mais après le
retrait de certains partenaires
financiers et de contraintes logistiques
et techniques les organisateurs de
l'événement ont décidé d'annuler le
festival à Saint-Germain la créativité
est au rendez-vous en tout cas la ville
va tenter de la valoriser cette
créativité tout à fait Grégory la
commune de Saint-Germain-en-Laye lance
sa deuxième édition de son budget
participatif alors pour améliorer la vie
à Saint-Germain-en-Laye la commune
propose à ses habitants de soumettre
leurs projets d'aménagement d'intérêt
général ils ont jusqu'au 12 mai pour
lister leurs idées et la ville elle se
propose de prendre en charge les projets
à hauteur de 150 000 euros pour plus
d'informations rendez-vous sur le site
je participe saint-germain-en-laye.fr et
on termine avec une information sport du
football et c'est sûrement la fin
désespoir de la montée en Ligue 2 pour
le FC Versailles ce mardi soir les
Versaillais se sont inclinés trois buts
à zéro à domicile contre le Red Star un
autre prétendant à la montée au
classement les joueurs de la cité royale
sont à la cinquième place à 5 points des
leagueurs Martigues et Concarneau le
championnat de National se termine dans
trois journées
avec attention aussi cette saison des
footballeurs de Versailles Tiphaine
exactement en fait on est on est un peu
sensible à tout ce qui se passe au
niveau Sport dans la Ville de Versailles
et effectivement je crois que c'est une
ville qui est hyper dynamique sur le
sport et puis il y a beaucoup de de
sport qui qui marche et qui marche bien
et dont le foot donc forcément oui on
est on est attentif et et effectivement
on aurait espéré pour eux qu'ils
puissent rejoindre la Ligue 2 ça aurait
été mis un beaucoup de projecteur sur la
ville et puis surtout les sports donc on
suit la route et on espère que que tous
les sports et dans le rugby suivra aussi
un petit peu les traces de du foot une
belle première saison quand même des
footballeurs Versailles en National
c'est aussi le cas pour les rugbymen
dans le championnat de Fédérale 2 on en
parle bien sûr tout à l'heure merci
Régine et si vous aussi comme d'habitude
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait qui vous a marqué n'hésitez pas à
le partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78
on parle dans un instant de la décision
attendue du Conseil constitutionnel les
sages doivent se prononcer ce soir sur
une demande déposée par plusieurs
parlementaires de gauchers du centre sur
un référendum pour abroger l'âge de
départ de l'égal à la retraite à 64 ans
Benjamin Lucas a député nupt de la 8e
circonscription des unes sera avec nous
dans quelques instants pour en parler
les retenus pour le moment à l'Assemblée
nationale en attendant ce chiffre
édifiant plus de 20 000 décès sont
recensés chaque année à cause
d'accidents de la vie courante selon à
l'Institut national de prévention et
d'éducation pour la santé il serait même
la première cause de mortalité chez les
enfants de 1 à 4 ans pour prévenir ses
incidents et former aux gestes qui
sauvent des ateliers sont proposés aux
parents et aux enfants à plaisir ils
sont assurés par et Déborah Agnès qui a
ouvert un récemment un centre de
périnatalité et de la femme le reportage
de Gabriel Gontier
comment réanimer un enfant qui ne
respire plus un bébé qui étouffe c'est à
force d'être confronté à ces questions
que Déborah Agnès infirmière de
profession a décidé de créer des
ateliers sur ces thématiques ce matin au
programme pour les parents de jéléna un
atelier pour apprendre les gestes de
premiers secours donc en fait le but ce
sera de tirer en gros
prendre une image et on revoit en gros
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque comme
risque
on voit qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre en
place parmi les incidents fréquents les
étouffements avec les petits objets les
brûlures ou encore les chutes sont
souvent source d'inquiétude chez les
parents
moi j'ai pris de l'escalier nous on a
des escaliers on a deux qu'on a les
escaliers classiques barré tous ces
premiers étages on voit aussi première
étage vous les combles ou c'est vraiment
des escaliers où il y a pas de rebords
il y a un trou entre chaque marche
d'accord donc là on va devoir installer
les barrières un peu partout
quel est le risque avec les escaliers
[Musique]
il faut savoir que la chute c'est
l'accident numéro 1 le but de ces
ateliers n'est pas de culpabiliser ou
d'effrayer mais plutôt de prévenir les
risques pour mieux les anticiper donc là
en l'occurrence avec les escaliers c'est
barrière en haut barrière en bas
obligatoire si on en est que une en haut
quand elle va commencer à grimper des
fois juste une chute de démarche ça
suffit après plusieurs années
d'expérience aux urgences l'infirmière
souhaitait donner un sens différent à
son métier à travers la pédagogie
l'échange et la pratique comme avec
cette simulation d'étouffement
comme ça on a le centre de gravité dans
l'urgence on le positionne comme on peut
d'accord
le but c'est de redonner confiance aux
parents et justement leur donner des
clés des outils pour que on n'arrive pas
au gestes d'urgence voilà leur dire un
accident reste un accident quoi qu'il
arrive il y a des choses qu'on peut pas
prévoir qu'on peut pas contrôler mais on
essaie de mettre en place le maximum de
choses pour éviter que il y ait une
brûlure qui est tel type de chute des
gestes qui peuvent s'avérer essentiels
en 2022 un million 700 000 accidents ont
été recensés pour les enfants de moins
de 15 ans 48% d'entre eux se produisant
à la maison
la Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines
poursuit ses rencontres partout en
Europe pour réfléchir aux initiatives
vers ton zone rurales et dernièrement la
structure s'est rendue en Allemagne dans
le land de rhénani Palatina une région
très forestière autour sur ce voyage
avec notre confrère de radio sensation
Corentin Alonso
une ferme biologique à plus grande
échelle voici une initiative qu'on peut
découvrir les délégations du projet
Guira une exploitation avec 250 vaches
et tout est 100% bio tout est basé sur
les produits naturels des animaux que
nous élevons nous-même nous utilisons
également le fumier produit par les
vaches comment Grais nous n'utilisons
pas de nourriture additionnelle les
animaux ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin
ici aujourd'hui l'agriculteur travaille
avec des grandes marques de
distributeurs allemands mais ils
développent également les circuits
courts
[Musique]
nous avons testé de nombreux biais pour
vendre notre viande et la meilleure
façon de faire et d'avoir des contacts
directs directement avec les
consommateurs qui viennent ici pour
visiter la ferme et acheter la viande
pas de marine Berg se situe dans la
région de westerworld un grand massif
forestier la forêt est donc un enjeu
environnemental ma cette région est
couverte de petites villes et villages
les ressources principales sont le bois
et les richesses présentes dans le sol
alors ce sont les forêts et les sols qui
sont ici les principales sources de
revenus en raison du changement
climatique nous nous sommes rendus
compte que nous devions absolument
protéger ses forêts les établissements
scolaires s'emparent des questions
environnementales dans ce lycée
technologique les élèves participent à
des ateliers de sensibilisation et
construisent des projets autour du
développement durable et ils ont bien
expliqué ici que par exemple il recycle
plutôt que d'acheter du neuf et ils ont
beaucoup d'ateliers qui permettent
d'expliquer à ces étudiants que recycler
c'est mieux que d'acheter du neuf et je
pense que cette sensibilisation qu'il
donne à ses étudiants leur permettent de
bien comprendre les enjeux qu'il y a
dans le dans le développement durable et
dans éviter de jeter jusqu'au plaisir et
de racheter du neuf les réflexions du
projet Guira se poursuivront puisque les
cinq délégations européennes sont
attendues dans les Yvelines le 12 juin
et pour en savoir plus sur l'actualité
européenne les missions zone Europe et
diffusées chaque samedi à 19h sur Radio
sensation et aussi sur TV 78
[Musique]
le sport à présent vous en parlez en
début d'émission à la fin de saison à
sonner pour le Rugby Club de Versailles
les Yvelinois ont été éliminés en
barrage de fédéral 2 une défaite
dimanche 27,6 sur la pelouse du Creusot
en Saône-et-Loire on revient sur le
match et sur la saison concluait la
sixième place de la phase régulière de
la poule 8 de Fédérale 2 avec les deux
invités du Rugby Club de Versailles on
le disait Tiphaine Sharon manager de
l'équipe première et également avec nous
Alexandre verlien qui est joueur de
l'équipe si on vient déjà sur cette
défaite Tiphaine est-ce qu'on peut
parler de défaite logique face on le
rappelle donc à une équipe c'était une
équipe que vous aviez joué à l'extérieur
et qui elle a terminé troisième de sa
poule la poule une en Fédérale 2 est-ce
que c'était une défaite logique c'est ça
c'était la poule de la Bourgogne donc
oui effectivement sur le papier c'était
c'était une défaite logique après en
ayant vécu le match maintenant avec du
recul on avait quand même les moyens et
il y avait quand même de la place pour
pouvoir faire quelque chose ce weekend
là et effectivement bah c'est pas passé
pour plusieurs raisons et on a laissé
beaucoup des plumes sur notre dernier
match au Havre pendant les phases
qualificatives et du coup on est parti
un petit peu là-bas un petit peu à moins
de risques surtout sur l'aspect un petit
peu humain avec des joueurs un peu
cadres importants qui ont beaucoup
manqué dans dans l'état d'esprit donc
c'est ça un petit peu les clés un petit
peu du match et pourquoi on a voilà il y
a un score quand même qui est assez
lourd puisque 27,6 c'est quand même un
score assez lourd mais 0 pour verser
exactement après et voilà il y a eu des
défaits de match on a pu on aurait pu
scorer dès le départ au bout de 5
minutes de jeu avec voilà de contraintes
qui étaient quasiment fait sur lequel on
aurait pu marquer et au final on reste à
3-0 on subit un petit peu sur cette
première mi-temps mais on reste collé
adoucisse on avait quand même
l'intention et on pensait que sur la la
deuxième mi-temps ils allaient baisser
un petit peu d'intensité et qu'on allait
pouvoir justement remettre la main sur
le ballon et pouvoir mettre un petit peu
plus de de production qui est un peu
notre ADN un petit peu de mettre du du
jeu et de la vitesse et bah ça a pas
fonctionné donc donc effectivement on
est déçu parce que on a rencontré des
équipes bien plus difficiles cette
saison on avait fait un très bon match à
la maison contre l'euro qui est qui a
fini trois quatrième de poule chez nous
et voilà on
il y avait la place c'est des regrets
aussi c'est le sentiment qui qui prévaut
à quelques jours après après cette
élimination malgré les faits de match le
fait aussi qui est beaucoup d'absents du
côté des Versaillais c'est aussi ça le
sentiment qui prévaut chez vous
aujourd'hui
par rapport à ça c'est vrai que après on
a eu du mal sur ce match voilà ils ont
bien contré sur nos points forts aussi
ils ont réussi à nous contrer et nous
moins du coup sur leur point fort en eux
c'est dommage parce que oui il y avait
on avait sûrement quelque chose à faire
est-ce qu'il y a quand même de la fierté
parce que on le disait on va y revenir
sur sur cette saison c'était quand même
une première en Fédérale 2 d'avoir cette
qualification embarrages dès la première
saison Fédérale 2 c'est aussi un
objectif suffit pas forcément avouer en
début de saison c'était plutôt le
maintien l'objectif avouer est-ce que la
fierté prévoit aussi aujourd'hui il y a
bien sûr évidemment puisque il y a le
premier sentiment qui est les objectifs
du club qui sont déterminés au début de
saison avec avec les joueurs et avec
l'ensemble voilà des stars puisque il y
a pas que l'équipe première il y a aussi
tout un staff derrière on a trois
équipes une équipe espoir et une équipe
régionale et donc c'est vrai que
l'objectif c'était le maintien donc à
partir du moment où on a assis en fait
ce ce ce
ticket de de maintien c'était une bonne
heure c'était que du bonus c'était aussi
après derrière une aventure d'hommes
puisque les nouveaux objectifs ont été
donnés par les joueurs et c'est vrai que
bah c'est des compétiteurs donc ils
auraient forcément aimé aller le plus
loin possible et encore une fois je le
dis voilà on a joué ce match et
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on avait les
capacités de pouvoir faire un peu mieux
et pourquoi pas
passer ce match de barrage du coup
Alexandre c'est un match qui va vous
servir
pour l'expérience pour la suite de des
aventures en Fédérale 2 pour la saison
prochaine alors moi du coup je m'inter
ma carrière c'est terminé pour
déménagement donc mais sinon oui oui
c'est un match qui va rester gravé
et une saison surtout qui va rester
gravé pardon avec des joueurs qui sont
toujours battus qui ont jamais rien
lâché parce qu'au début de saison
c'était le maintien il était pas fait
sur les deux premiers mois bien sûr donc
on n'a jamais arraché et on a toujours
voulu aller toujours plus loin donc pour
vos coéquipiers qui vont rester ce sera
une expérience nécessaire et et qui va
qui va servir pour la saison prochaine
oui oui complètement alors la Fédérale
on le disait une découverte pour le
Rugby Club de Versailles cette saison
promus de fédéral 3 en début de saison
objectif maintien on en a on en a parlé
et vous avez réussi donc à arracher
cette place en barrage en terminant
sixième de votre poule et ce qu'on
débute saison Tiphaine Charlotte vous
attendiez à Paris performance des dès le
début de saison de de vos joueurs comme
on dit toujours si on avait signé pour
la les plaques sont de leur effet tout
de suite et puis on aurait été plus
serein dès le départ et puis on aurait
certainement moins stressé en début de
saison mais non on n'avait pas du tout
imaginé ça on savait que on rentrait
dans une division qui était forte voilà
et que il va falloir qu'il aurait fallu
redoubler d'efforts et on a un groupe
extraordinaire avec des joueurs vraiment
qui ont réussi complètement à s'adapter
à produire les efforts au quotidien pour
pouvoir justement être éligible et
performé sur cette division donc oui
effectivement on est très content très
satisfait et les joueurs peuvent être
très contents de leur de cette saison
puisque ils ont réalisé vraiment quelque
chose de bah je vais dire
d'extraordinaire puisque au final le
club de Versailles n'a jamais été en
fédéral 2 donc il écrit encore une fois
l'histoire en se positionnant sur cette
division et en même temps il écrit une
deuxième fois l'histoire puisque on
arrache une qualification donc voilà on
a deux tickets qui sont plutôt flatteurs
pour le pour le un CV saison de la
progression si on l'a senti alors au
travers des deux derby yvelinois il y a
eu des matchs à plaisir un match c'est
vrai à l'aller ou Versailles était
largement dominé sur la pelouse de
plaisir 44,7 c'était beaucoup moins vrai
au retour 19 30 au stade Montmoron on a
senti quand même la progression
finalement une saison d'apprentissage au
début vous étiez novice dans cette cette
division de Fédérale 2 mais il y a eu un
apprenti sage au cours de la saison oui
au fur et à mesure de chaque match on a
on a progressé sur le premier bloc sur
les trois premiers matchs a été
on a perdu Saint-Malo le premier match
ou ça joue à pas grand chose ou à la fin
on peut gagner après on du coup on perd
beaucoup contre le plaisir et derrière
on rebondit petit à petit on a remis la
marchand avant on a beaucoup bossé à
l'entraînement pour essayer de performer
au mieux et réussir cette saison une
question sur la saison prochaine
j'imagine que vous travaillez déjà sur
la saison prochaine est-ce que il y a
déjà des secteurs que vous avez
identifié où il faut renforcer l'équipe
on vu la saison prochaine oui exactement
en fait on a comme vous le savez on a il
y a un plan de route qui a été créé
auprès du RCV depuis maintenant 4 ans
l'objectif premium c'était justement de
de d'aller dans cette division fédérale
2 c'était une attente globale du club
des partenaires de la direction et aussi
des joueurs puisque faut savoir que on
travaille énormément sur le sur les
jeunes que ce soit l'école de rugby les
U16 et les 18 c'est des des joueurs qui
performent aussi eux parce qu'ils jouent
une division nationale et qui rencontre
aussi des des gros clubs et il était
important pour nous que ces jeunes là
puissent rester au club et jouer au
meilleur niveau donc ça c'était la
première la partie la première bataille
a gagné donc ce qu'on a réussi cette
saison la deuxième maintenant c'est un
nouveau nouveau challenge faut savoir
que voilà on a des nouvelles
infrastructures qui arriveront
certainement en septembre 2025 il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vont être mis en
place voilà pour faire développer faire
évoluer le club donc maintenant
l'objectif c'est bien évidemment de
faire mieux de stabiliser le club en
Fédérale 2 et de pouvoir d'ici 2025
prétendre à faire mieux donc le RCV veut
s'installer dans le 78 comme le club
phare du département donc aujourd'hui
l'équipe encadrante et dirigeante fait
en sorte de de donner les moyens de le
faire donc avec un budget peut-être qui
va augmenter on sait que les adversaires
disent que Versailles en général a le
plus gros budget de la poule de Fédérale
2 le budget va rester le même va
augmenter alors déjà d'une c'est une
fausse thé puisque on n'est pas du tout
le plus gros budget de la fédérale 2
loin de là on a un budget qui est je
pense assez consé pour pouvoir rivaliser
en Fédérale 2 après faut savoir qu'un
budget c'est un budget global dans les
clubs donc ça veut dire que c'est un
budget qui est réparti par toutes les
catégories et que nous aujourd'hui par
rapport aux autres clubs on a beaucoup
de dépenses sur les jeunes comme je vous
l'ai dit on a des U18 nationaux qui se
déplacent il faut des cas on a deux
équipes on a une entente avec avec Le
Chesnay avec les hits les U16 on a aussi
une équipe nationale à U16 donc ça
demande des déplacements ça demande des
éducateurs donc ça demande beaucoup
beaucoup d'investissements pour le club
et c'est vrai qu'il y a une grosse
partie du budget qui est qui est allouée
sur l'école de rugby puisque on essaie
de travailler par le bas et je pense que
c'est ça aussi la réussite du RCV c'est
de pas tout mettre et tout capitaliser
sur le groupe senior et une mais
vraiment de distribuer justement le
budget afin que tout est catégories
puisse vraiment être dans les meilleures
conditions et prendre du plaisir merci
en tout cas d'être venu en parler en
plateau c'est vrai que la formation
Versailles est souvent louée Merci à
VOUS Tiphaine charol manager de l'équipe
première bravo pour cette saison bravo
également à vous Alexandre et bonne
suite de parcours du si vous continuez
le rugby vous arrêtez je vais sûrement
continuer mais en loisir et bien bonne
continuation à vous et merci d'être venu
parler de cette saison du RCV merci en
plateau zoom à présent sur un événement
sportif ça se passe du 4 au 10 juin
prochain 14 duo vont participer au
rallye naturelle aventure première
course 100% féminine et 100 % électrique
au monde départ déviant-les-bains pour 5
jours d'étape au coeur des paysages de
Savoie et de Haute-Savoie parmi les
participantes et des yvelinoises qui se
sont entraînés justement il y a quelques
jours dans les rues de Versailles le
reportage de Céline Charles
dépassement de soi découverte et
rencontre c'est ce qui attend les 14
binômes d'aventurière au départ du
rallye naturel aventure une compétition
alliant conduite de véhicules
électriques et étape en trek mais avant
le grand départ le 4 juin prochain leur
est à la préparation pendant une journée
et demi elles vont suivre une formation
par notre directeur sportif est plongé
au cœur d'une mini aventure d'une
journée et demi pour comprendre
finalement le challenge en lui-même et
en général quand elle sort de la prime
journée de nuit elles sont rassurées et
prêtes à démarrer l'aventure lire des
cartes naviguer avec un livre de route
utilisait des boussoles ou encore
conduire de manière éco-responsable
autant de compétences qui ne
s'improvisent pas sur la ligne de départ
plusieurs yvelinoises avec leur binôme
alors on sait connaît depuis presque
vingtaine d'années
on a on a fait les études ensemble dans
la même université à Orléans et on est
monté sur Paris dans le début au milieu
des années 2000 on est toutes les deux
passionnés de voiture à l'envie de faire
des challenges on a déjà fait ensemble
des courses à pied notre entreprise BMW
Florence doré nous ont proposé ce
challenge lors de la journée des femmes
on se connaissait pas on a discuté on a
on s'est fait un petit déjeuner un petit
resto et hop là on s'est retrouvé on
s'est dit hop on peut faire le challenge
voilà
une compétition de 5 jours avec un
classement quotidien et final mais pour
ces femmes c'est avant tout une aventure
humaine on est trop sur nos téléphones
et on ne fait pas attention à ce qu'ils
nous entoure justement là on va observer
la nature on va observer les gens on va
les écouter et je pense que c'est ce qui
nous manque aujourd'hui là on a amène la
femme le véhicule et l'environnement en
même temps en plus avec un côté
électrique qui est très très forte
aujourd'hui d'actualité on a toutes les
deux défis je pense que c'est important
l'exemple qu'on donne à nos enfants à
chaque inscription naturelle aventure
reverse une partie des frais à
maternelle une association créée en
support du rallye elle a vocation a
soutenir des projets en faveur de
l'environnement cette année pour 2023
c'est un partenariat avec la clairière
paysanne à Magny-les-Hameaux et ça a
permis de financer du matériel agricole
pour leur activité plus particulièrement
pendant le rallye où on va aller sur la
région Savoie Haute-Savoie travailler
avec les villes partenaires Annecy et
Vian l'année dernière 3000 euros ont été
récoltés si vous souhaitez vous lancer
le défi naturel Aventure propose
également une édition en Norvège le
départ est prévu le 19 août prochain
comme chaque mercredi on va faire le
point sur l'actualité cinéma un jour de
sortie dans les celles obscures
Sébastien est-ce que vous avez
l'occasion de vous rendre régulièrement
au cinéma ce que vous êtes un fan de
cinéma ça fait très très longtemps que
j'ai pas été au cinéma et je profite
allègrement des systèmes de vidéos la
demande qui existe aujourd'hui et j'ai
deux enfants qui sont jeunes et du coup
je sors plus énormément et surtout pas
au cinéma bon en tout cas en face de
vous avez essayé Charles bonsoir Céline
de la rédaction tv70 qui vient chaque
semaine en plateau pour faire le point
justement sur les films à ne pas manquer
et qui sortent au cinéma chaque mercredi
alors pour commencer votre sélection
vous nous proposez le retour de la bande
rock n' roll de l'univers Marvel de
groots
là j'ai bien nommé bien sûr les gardiens
de la galaxie la bande reprend du
service pour un troisième et dernier
opus centrer cette fois-ci sur Rocket le
laveur cyborg dont on apprendra
l'histoire personnelle et les origines
la folle équipe va devoir voler à la
rescousse de leur ami le sauver des
mains du maître de l'évolution ce savant
fou un peu dérangé et bien décidé à
faire du pauvre roquette son rat de
laboratoire pour essayer de percer les
secrets de son intelligence le tout dans
le but de créer un peuple parfait pour
la suite et oui il est très ambitieux
cet antagoniste un film Marvel qui
mélange humour camaraderie action et
émotion regardez
[Musique]
on a toujours été en quête d'une famille
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rencontre
vous êtes prêts pour une dernière virée
alors si nous revient en France avec une
comédie qui mêle sport et sujet
sociétaux et oui ce film c'est un peu
une ode aux valeurs du rugby surtout
dans les villages ruraux du sud de la
France pour l'honneur réalisé par
Philippe Guillard ancien joueur de rugby
raconte l'histoire de deux villages du
sud de la France alors accrochez-vous
bien tourtour les Bains et troc-pon sur
tes scout alors les deux villages se
livrent une guerre de clocher symbolisés
par un derby entre les deux clubs de
rugby alors que le premier enchaîne les
défaites l'arrivée d'une dizaine de
réfugiés dans le village va peut-être
changer la donne le coach du rugby qui
est interprété par Olivier Marchal va se
donner la mission de les intégrer à
travers le sport et il a bien
l'intention de gagner le match de
l'année regarder quand tu vas vers
l'avant il faut toujours rester derrière
à une condition c'est que la passe soit
faite à la main parce que c'est l'effet
au pied elle peut être en avant
[Musique]
purement
jette un œil au départ des migrants
[Musique]
je te garantis qu'ils vont te mettre la
misère aujourd'hui derby
il était emprisonné torturé pendant deux
ans Salifou a sauvé et comme le petit
n'avait pas de famille il en a fait son
petit frère c'est ça que j'appelle le
courage
non c'est des problèmes sociétaux de
racisme et d'exclusion mais qui choisit
l'humour et la bienveillance pour
l'illustrer il mais surtout en avant le
côté fédérateur du sport et en prime
Francis Cabrel également fan de rugby a
composé on arrive demain une musique
inédite juste pour le film et on termine
Céline avec un autre film français plus
sombre cette fois oui beaucoup plus
sombre puisqu'il s'intéresse aux
attentats aux attentats du 13 novembre
2015 un an une nuit du réalisateur
espagnol isaquent la Cuesta c'est
l'histoire d'un couple qui s'est
retrouvé pris dans l'aurore de
l'attentat du Bataclan alors qu'ils ont
réussi à sortir physiquement indemne de
la salle côté psychologique c'est une
autre histoire le film montre le
parcours de reconstitution du couple et
surtout la manière dont chacun va gérer
le traumatisme à la suite de l'attentat
chacun va adopter les des attitudes
différentes l'un va se plonger dans le
déni tandis que l'autre au contraire va
se laisser aller à ses émotions et
revivre en boucle les événements le film
se base sur un livre paix amour et DAF
métal de l'espagnol Ramon Gonzalez un
survivant de la tuerie merci Céline pour
votre est-ce qu'autour de la table vous
avez fait votre choix
peut-être un film que vous allez
attendre qui sort sur une plateforme
une plateforme de de streaming le
deuxième parce que le deuxième sur le
rugby sur le rugby il a l'air de toucher
à des sujets qui sont sensibles avec des
notes d'humour et je pense que c'est
important de rappeler que ces sujets
sont importants et puis de dire qu'on
peut aussi souvent en rire c'est vrai
qu'il me plaît bien aussi celui-là je
pense qu'il aurait pu aussi à nos
invités du Rugby Club de Versailles
Céline moi
je choisir le troisième un an une
nuit alors comme chaque mercredi aussi
on redécouvre on découvre un classique
un film qui est déjà sorti au cinéma
peut-être disponible également à
Sébastien sur une plateforme de
streaming nombreuses plateformes de
streaming alors ce soir c'est un film
peu connu sorti en 2007 qui s'appelle
héros film français ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose ça vous évoque un lointain
souvenirs seulement de nous alors il est
sorti en 2007 avec au casting notamment
Michael Youn c'est un film réalisé par
Bruno Merle et c'est le coup de cœur ce
mercredi de notre réalisateur et Benoît
Thomas Salazar
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de mon
coup de coeur il s'agit d'un film pas
très très connu qui est sorti en 2007 et
qui s'appelle héros qui est réalisé et
écrit par Bruno merle c'est histoire
d'un chauffeur de salle qui s'appelle
Pierre Fauré et qui est joué par Michael
Youn qui est ici dans un rôle très
dramatique on a pas du tout l'habitude
de le voir comme ça donc ce chauffeur de
salle qui s'appelait Pierre Fauré il est
très rigolo tout le monde l'adore mais
il aimerait être pris au sérieux il voit
qu'on ne prend pas au sérieux et donc
qu'est-ce qui va faire il va un peu
péter péter un câble et il va kidnapper
un des chanteurs les plus connus qui
s'appelle Clovis Costa qui est joué par
Patrick Chesnais voilà le vis Costa
c'est un petit peu l'équivalent de
Johnny Hallyday par exemple et il va le
kidnapper les policiers vont lui
demander quels sont ses revendications
et Pierre Fauré répond qu'il veut être
pris au sérieux donc ce film il est très
intéressant sur deux choses déjà c'est
le premier film de son réalisateur Bruno
Bruno Merle et vraiment la réalisation
c'est vraiment des parties pris quoi on
nous donne pas toutes les clés il faut
s'accrocher pour pour comprendre on est
vraiment plongé dans une ambiance hyper
intimiste hyper cérébral dans un appart
quasiment vidé parce que c'est un huis
clos un quasiment tout film se passe
dans l'appartement de pierre-forêt ou il
a pris en otage du coup ce chanteur et
aussi ce qui est hyper intéressant dans
ce film c'est du coup la prestation de
Mickey qui est vraiment impressionnante
en 2007 il sort quand même de il y a pas
eu encore fatal il sort de La Beuze il
sort du Morning life donc vraiment en
fait c'est clairement ce personnage hein
les cailloux c'est carrément pierre
forêt quelqu'un qui fait rire qui fait
bien rire et que jamais notre vie on
aurait pris au sérieux mais dans ce film
vraiment on on le prend complètement au
sérieux c'est assez bluffant Patrick
Chenet aussi est très très bon et voilà
je peux que vous me conseiller de devoir
ce film c'est vraiment une très bonne
surprise surtout pour pour sa fin et
pour et pour son message au final
[Musique]
on va faire une petite pause politique
dans cette édition on le disait en début
de 7 8 les sages doivent trancher ce
soir des parlementaires de gauche et du
centre ont déposé une deuxième demande
pour l'organisation d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée pour revenir à
l'âge légal de la retraite à 62 ans le
Conseil constitutionnel doit rendre sa
décision dans les prochaines minutes
plusieurs confrères elle parle d'une
décision rendue à 19h et pour en parler
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle maintenant
il vient de nous rejoindre le député de
la 8e circonscription des Yvelines
Benjamin Lucas est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir
bonsoir
ça alors le 14 avril dernier une
première demande pour un RIP un
référendum d'initiative partagée avait
été déjà rejeté par les sages qu'est-ce
que cette deuxième demande à de si
différent est-ce que vous avez espoir
qu'elle aboutissent là on va avoir la
décision d'ici quelques minutes à 19
heures
écoutez oui j'ai bon espoir je le crois
parce que je l'espère beaucoup
évidemment elle a de différents
certaines modalités juridiques c'est
parce que nous avions justement senti
que la première demande pouvait poser un
certain nombre de questions juridiques
que celle-ci a été retravaillée de façon
de façon différente et donc nous
attendons évidemment la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel parce que je
crois que ce référendum d'initiative
partagé serait une manière de sortir de
la crise profonde et notamment la crise
démocratique dans laquelle nous a plongé
le président de la République par sa
brutalité et par sa surdité à l'égard du
mouvement populaire qui s'exprime dans
notre pays depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant
si il y a validation du Conseil
constitutionnel si le rip est jugé
conforme c'est le début d'un long
parcours il faudra ensuite recueillir un
dixième des signatures des électeurs
donc
4,87 millions de personnes avant tout un
de signatures le tout dans un délai de
neuf mois en sachant que dans ce laps de
temps là la réforme des retraites ne
sera pas gelée pour autant c'est un long
combat qui s'annonce s'il y a validation
ce soir
oui mais le combat ne nous fait pas peur
ça fait des semaines maintenant que nous
sommes comme des millions de Françaises
et de français mobilisés contre cette
réforme des retraites et je crois qu'il
y aurait une forme de noblesse
démocratique dans un moment de crise
dans lequel nos compatriotes vu le 49.3
brutalisé le Parlement dans lequel ils
ont vu le mouvement social historique on
a eu un 1er mai il y avait 10 fois plus
de monde que que l'année précédente
complètement passé sous silence par le
par le pouvoir politique par Emmanuel
Macron et son gouvernement il y a besoin
d'un réveil démocratique que nos
concitoyens le veulent et donc moi je
pense que si ce référendum d'initiative
partagé et validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel nous n'aurons aucune
difficulté à obtenir les presque 5
millions de signatures nécessaires
est-ce qu'il y a un référendum
évidemment je suis convaincu que très
largement mais son âge de démontre
d'ailleurs nous l'emporterons pour
mettre fin à cette réforme des retraites
qui est vécue par nos compatriotes comme
une incroyable brutalité comme une très
grande injustice et puis qui n'a pas de
fondement démocratique puisqu'elle n'a
été approuvée ni par l'Assemblée
nationale il y a pas eu de vote
l'Assemblée nationale ni par le peuple
français qui est très majoritairement
hostile à cette à ce passage de la
retraite à 64 ans les sondages disent 7
à 8 Français sur 10 9 actif sur 10 donc
c'est quand même la quasi totalité la
quasi illimité du pays
puis pas non plus pas plus par les corps
intermédiaires les organisations
syndicales or la démocratie sociale ça
compte surtout quand on se revendique du
progressisme comme le fait Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 si vous êtes certain
d'arriver à mobiliser sur un référendum
d'initiative partagée on rappelle juste
que sur le dernier alors qui était sur
un tout autre sujet c'est la
privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris il y
avait seulement un million de signatures
qui avaient été recueillies bien loin
des 4,87 millions de signatures
nécessaires
côté je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que
s'il se référer un homme d'initiative
partagée est validé nous obtiendrons les
5 millions de signatures et même bien
plus je vais vous dire il y a dans la
8ème circonscription des Yvelines dont
je suis l'élu pas une journée par une
réunion publique par une visite sur un
marché à la sortie d'une école ou dans
n'importe quel autre manifestation
publique dans laquelle je me trouve dans
laquelle je n'ai pas des gens qui
viennent me dire qu'ils sont prêts à
signer pour qu'il y ait référendum à se
mobiliser à voter contre cette réforme
des retraites et une demande de
démocratie il y a une demande de justice
sociale je pense que ces deux demandes
se rencontreront dans ce référendum
d'initiative partagé donc je n'ai aucun
doute et puis après il y a évidemment
une mobilisation à mener et j'invite
celles et ceux qui nous regardent
notamment dans la 8ème circonscrit
circonscription des Yvelines avant de la
jolie animée à Mantes-la-Ville dans le
vaccin à Gargenville à Porcheville ou
ailleurs à se rapprocher de moi de mes
équipes et puis à se mobiliser avec nous
soit si un référendum d'initiative pour
aller collecter des signatures soit s'il
n'y a pas pour continuer la mobilisation
et pour construire alternatives Emmanuel
Macron évidemment tout ça bien sûr s'il
y a validation du Conseil
constitutionnel la décision qui devrait
être rendue à 19h alors si il y a rejet
du Rip il y a une autre date en ligne de
mire hein c'est celle du 8 juin qui est
celle du jour de l'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale d'une proposition de loi du
groupe liotte pour ne pas faire
appliquer la réforme des retraites les
oppositions de la nupes et du
rassemblement national pour voter pour
le texte le texte comme cela avait été
le cas pour la motion de censure qui
avait été déjà déposé à l'époque par ce
groupe liotte à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous pensez que des députés
aussi les républicains pourraient se
joindre à cet élan pour avoir une chance
de faire aboutir justement cette
proposition de loi
oui d'abord juste une précision c'est un
texte qui est porté sur la journée
d'initiative parlementaire du groupe
violette mais c'est un texte dont par
exemple moi qui suis député la nupette
je suis signataire donc c'est un texte
qui est déjà assez largement cosiné les
collègues socialistes avaient aussi fait
cette proposition donc c'est un texte
commun pour abrocher cette réforme des
retraites oui moi je suis extrêmement
confiant pourquoi il y a eu 49 3 le 16
mars dernier il y a eu le retour au 49
fois par le gouvernement parce que il y
avait clairement une majorité de
parlementaires une majorité de députés à
l'Assemblée nationale qui aurait voté
contre cette réforme des retraites c'est
pour ça qu'Elisabeth borne Emmanuel
Macron on fait le choix de passer en
force et de ne pas aller au vote donc le
8 juin et bien ce sera en transparence
là il y a pas de 49,3 possible donc les
Françaises et les Français seront et
pourront voir qui voulaient faire
travailler deux années de plus de les
faire souffrir à l'âge de la retraite
qui veut les privés de deux années de
bonheur et des années de repos et qui
soutient la progression de cette réforme
moi je suis convaincu que ce soit vous
le disiez avec des parlementaires
d'ailleurs moi j'en appelle ou alors je
crois qu'on a fondé la sécurité sociale
dans ce pays un stand d'avancée parfois
avec un consensus entre communiste
socialiste égoïste et donc j'en appelle
à l'esprit gaulliste des républicains là
ce qui est en jeu c'est pas finalement
ça va au-delà du clivage entre la gauche
et la droite ce qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui c'est notre modèle social et
puis c'est le respect de la volonté du
peuple français qui rejette quasi
unanimement cette réforme des retraites
et puis c'est le respect de ce qui s'est
passé le 19 juin dernier puisque le
président de la République n'a pas eu la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
notamment à cause de sa réforme des
retraites et de son projet intéressant
de les retraites donc finalement je
crois je suis convaincurant à des
collègues de LR et
et qu'on connaît qui ont d'ailleurs voté
la motion de censure mais aussi d'autres
qui se joigneront à nous voir pour faire
obstacle et cette raison des retraites
donc le référendum d'initiative partagée
cette proposition de loi est-ce que
c'est à vos yeux les dernières chances
qui vous restent pour essayer de faire
reculer le gouvernement on l'a bien
compris le gouvernement on a pas l'air
de vouloir reculer sur sur cette réforme
de retraite
oui le gouvernement essaie de dire faut
passer à autre chose et le chemin
démocratique est terminé mais dans une
démocratie il y a jamais de fin du
chemin tout ce qui a été fait voter par
l'Assemblée nationale peut être défait
et moi je vous le dis même si le 8 juin
nous ne gagnions pas à sia obstruction
du gouvernement et de la majorité
présidentielle à chaque occasion nous le
pourrons nous déposerons une proposition
d'abrogation de cette réforme des
retraites le combat ne sera pas terminé
tant que cette réforme ne sera pas
abrogée et puis il y aura des échéances
électorales et des élections moi je
travaille avec les collègues de la
dépêche à maintenir l'unité à construire
des propositions politiques pour nous
arrivions au pouvoir et que nous
abrogions cette réforme si elle n'a pas
été abattue avant sauf que il y a une
urgence qui est d'épargné les Françaises
et les Français on peut pas attendre
2027 donc nous nous allons nous battre à
chaque fois que nous le pourrons
évidemment on soutient de l'Inter
syndicale du mouvement social et des
décisions qui prend marre mais aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale à choc l'occasion
qui nous sera offerte qui nous sera
permise par les institutions par les
règles de notre vie démocratique et bien
nous la saisirons pour aborder cette
réforme des retraites et je suis certain
que le 8 juin nous aurons une première
victoire politique et parlementaire avec
le vote de la disposition que nous avons
faites d'abordations de cette réforme
des retraites merci Benjamin Lucas
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
député UPS de la 8e circonscription des
Yvelines un décision du Conseil
constitutionnel attendu pour 19h et on
précise aussi un que le 6 juin aura lieu
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale contre la
réforme des retraites
[Musique]
tout autre sujet pour bientôt arriver à
au terme de cette émission lisait tout à
l'heure Sébastien Rosset vous êtes le
cogérant de la brasserie au cloques
browing qui est situé à Bois-d'Arcy vous
avez participé donc au Paris à Beer
festival c'est un rendez-vous dédié à la
bière artisanale qui va se dérouler du 8
au 14 mai une semaine d'animation
d'animation qui va se conclure aux
grandes contrôles à Paris avec un final
de cet événement c'est la première fois
que vous participez à cet événement vous
avez l'habitude d'y participer c'est la
dixième édition cette année alors on a
participé à toutes les éditions depuis
que la brasserie existe ce qui fait
qu'on a dû participer à cette édition si
je dis pas de si je dis pas de bêtises
pour nous c'est un rendez-vous c'est un
rendez-vous important
la bière artisanale française
francilienne tout à fait alors c'est un
événement important parce que ça met en
valeur labyr artisanale à Paris et c'est
ça qui est c'est ça qui est intéressant
au-delà de ça ça met aussi en valeur les
produits
produits en région Île-de-France et
et surtout le territoire
ce qui est ce qui est super important
pour nous c'est que c'est un événement
qui rassemble énormément de énormément
de gens qui rassemblait vraiment
énormément de brasserie
en un seul lieu ce qui fait que ça crée
une espèce d'émulsion qui est très très
intéressante et comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est vraiment une grande fête
de la bière artisanale à Paris vous
pensez que la bière on peut la mettre au
même niveau que le vin on sait que le
vin c'est un patrimoine français ce que
la bière mérite d'être d'avoir ces
lettres de noblesse aussi je pense que
la bière mérite d'avoir ces lettres de
noblesse je pense que la bière est en
train de reprendre un petit peu de la
force avec ce qui se passe c'est dix
dernières années
on est a priori sur les premières années
où les Français consomment plus de bière
que de vin donc c'est c'est déjà
intéressant maintenant pour parler de
patrimoine pour parler tout ça c'est
vraiment difficile de comparer de
comparer deux produits qui sont qui sont
claire différents on a un produit qui
est clairement ancré dans l'histoire de
notre pays qui est le vent et on a la
bière qui était qui était qui faisait
partie de notre pays et qui a finalement
disparu mais qui est en train de
reprendre du poil de la bête et ce qui
est bien c'est que c'est la partie
artisanale qui fait remonter le produit
et ça c'est une belle chose il faut la
défendre ce quota artisanal peut-être
aussi local de la bière nous aujourd'hui
je défends les artisans les producteurs
qui font de l'artisanat qui viennent de
de n'importe où dans le pays je les
défends parce que ouais aujourd'hui on a
des concurrents industriels qui ont des
forces de frappes qui sont bien bien
supérieur aux autres
et donc ouais du coup aujourd'hui on
vend notre brasserie on vend notre bière
mais je suis très content de parler de
tous mes confrères et tous mes tous nos
amis en fait alors dans vos description
on retrouve souvent le fait que vous
souhaitez vous éloigner du modèle
français justement proposer des bières
un peu différentes c'est quoi le style
de clock alors s'éloigner du modèle
français cette formulation a été
certainement plus valable il y a 7 ans
que aujourd'hui elle est presque elle
est presque désuète cette cette
formulation mais l'idée c'est de dire on
a clivé en France la bière dans un
modèle de couleur qui était la bière
blonde la bière brune la bière ambrée et
c'est quelque chose qui quelque part
existe que dans notre pays et on a
complètement mis de côté tous les styles
de bière qui pouvaient exister et c'est
un peu comme si on avait réduit on va
reparler du vin du coup mais c'est un
peu comme si on avait réduit le vin aux
couleurs et finalement on arrive chez un
caviste et puis on dit bah voilà ce soir
je les ai mis je voudrais du blanc et
puis on prend n'importe quel n'importe
quel blanc sans s'intéresser au cépage
nous chez outlook on s'est intéressé aux
origines de chacun des styles de bière
et pourquoi est-ce que ils sont venus et
de quelle
qualité pourquoi en fait quelle est
l'histoire de cette de ce style et du
coup effectivement on n'a pas une bière
qui s'appelle la blonde ou une bière qui
s'appelle Lambret on a des bières qui
portent le nom des styles qu'elle sont
et vous travaillez avec des acteurs
locaux du coup c'est ça fait partie de
votre ADN c'est difficile pour nous
travailler avec des acteurs locaux on a
très peu de malteries en France et on a
un très très gros acteur dans le malt
mais qui est une balterie industrielle
qui travaille avec toutes les brasseries
industrielles du coup on exporte on
importe nos
Maltes et les houblons sont importés
également et est-ce que la période est
difficile on sait que les brasseurs ont
pu connaître des difficultés justement
liées à aux matières premières qu'ils
utilisent est-ce que c'est votre cas
alors la matière première la période est
difficile clairement on est dans une
période compliquée on espère que le
soleil qui revient va faire ressortir un
petit peu les les gens parce que on en
est à se dire que les gens ont sorte
moins en tout cas ils consomment moins
c'est sûr
les matières premières il y a eu d'abord
l'effet covid qui a fait fortement
augmenter les matières premières
l'Ukraine étant l'un des principales
producteurs de céréales dans l'Europe la
grande nul le conflit en Ukraine a fait
énormément changer les les prix évoluer
les prix des céréales et de la et la
Russie est aussi un gros producteur de
verre donc du coup ça nous a fait
augmenter le prix du verre mais c'est
aussi un gros producteur de capsule donc
en fait c'est toute la filière qui a été
touchée à ce moment-là qui était déjà
bien impacté par le par le covid et puis
la dernièrement c'est l'énergie quoi
l'énergie là on l'a l'énergie clairement
ça a été une coup de massue parce que
nous en tant que là je parle en tant que
brasserie au cloque à Bois-d'Arcy on a
multiplié par 10 notre coup de
production donc on est passé très
compliqué très compliqué mais vous le
dites l'important c'est de la mettre en
avant cette brasserie artisanale ce
savoir faire artisanal donc il y a cet
événement
après une période difficile il y a
toujours une période qui est plus
positive on l'a vécu nous clairement là
ce qui s'est passé après le confinement
c'était génial on a trouvé qu'il y avait
un élan de de enfin les gens étaient
contents étaient contents de sortir les
gens étaient contents de retrouver les
terrasses
j'imagine que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en France ça aide pas les
gens à sortir non plus bien festival
pour inciter les gens à sortir on pourra
vous retrouver justement aux grandes
contrôles à Paris sur les deux derniers
jours de l'événement qu'est-ce que vous
allez proposer qu'est-ce qu'on pourra
retrouver alors nous sur ce festival
l'idée c'est de proposer de la nouveauté
on est sur un festival où on sait qu'on
arrive avec un public qui nous connaît
déjà
on joue à la maison donc du coup bah il
faut proposer de la nouveauté donc on va
certainement proposer les dernières
sorties les dernières bières qui sont
sortis de YouTube
l'idée c'est d'arriver à rencontrer nos
clients à rencontrer les gens qui
consomment nos bières c'est aussi de
rencontrer nos collègues parce que faut
pas se le cacher c'est quand même une
deux journées où on est des brasseurs
qui viennent de toute la France donc il
y a énormément d'échanges il y a
beaucoup de choses qui s'organisent
aussi entre nous à ce moment-là
donc voilà l'idée c'est de c'est de
rassembler les gens autour d'un produit
qui est assez festif et et de le montrer
dans un jour un peu nouveau et dans
quelques jours de de
j'ai envie de dire de de festifs mais
pas
[Musique]
pas trop festif dernière question
peut-être un peu piège que je vais vous
demander de la faire très courte
qu'est-ce qu'une bonne bière pour vous
une bonne bière c'est une bière où il y
a pas 10000 ingrédients une bonne bière
il y a 4 ingrédients il y a de l'eau du
Malte de la levure et du houblon c'est
tout c'est tout c'est la recette du
succès en tout cas on pourra retrouver
les bières au cloques lors du pari bear
festival donc ça se déroule toute la
semaine prochaine c'est du 8 au 14 mai
avec plein d'animations en France et
donc un final qui se déroulera aux
grandes contrôles à Paris les 13 et 14
mai merci Sébastien Rosset d'être venu
en parler en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes le cogérant de la brasserie au
cloques Bray wing qui est situé à
Bois-d'Arcy merci beaucoup avant de se
quitter retour sur un événement qui
avait lieu cette fois-ci le week-end
dernier prox raide aventure qui vise à
rapprocher la police les pompiers et la
population a fait étape au centre
d'incendie et de ce cours de plaisir
pour une quatrième édition une journée
citoyenne et sportive sur laquelle
reviennent Mickaël midoro et Ludivine
canard
faute démonstration d'une arrestation
équestre mais vrai policiers police
nationale police municipale et pompiers
étaient présents pour faire découvrir
après de 300 visiteurs les différentes
facettes du métier geste de premier
secours démonstration de la brigade
cynophile initiation à l'escalade et à
la boxe mais aussi à la tyrolienne ils
vont équiper des enfants ou des adultes
ça peut être tout le monde tous les âges
pour pouvoir faire un parcours avec les
équipements de policiers et le temps pas
le casque et le justaucorps pour voir le
poids
c'était un peu lourd c'est super les
deux les enfants apprennent plein de
choses là il voit comment ça se passe
une interpellation il y a plein de
stands il voit comment interviennent les
pompiers en proposant ses activités
pompiers et policiers espèrent changer
leur image auprès du public mais là
justement pour leur expliquer comment ça
se déroule pour répondre à leurs
questions et leur montrer que on peut
être aussi de très belles personnes à
travers l'uniforme aujourd'hui les
interventions de police et de pompiers
sont pas forcément tout le temps sereine
et c'est ce genre d'événements ça permet
d'avoir des échanges informels entre la
population et les policiers pompiers
dans un moment d'amusement en fait cet
événement est aussi l'occasion de
susciter des vocations policiers ça a
l'air trop bien on peut monter à cheval
on a des menottes on a un taser on a un
pistolet au cas où
un événement qui devrait se reproduire
chaque année la police nationale recrute
plusieurs centaines d'officiers
[Musique]
allez pour terminer dernier coup d'oeil
aux prévisions météo de demain
éclaircies et température assez douce en
matinée dans les Yvelines vous le voyez
même condition à annoncer sur l'ensemble
du territoire avec une température de 13
degrés dans l'après-midi peu ou pas
d'évolution prévoyez toujours quelques
éclaircis côté thermomètre 22 degrés
sont annoncés sur les secteurs de
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles ou dans et
Rambouillet voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dès demain pour une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]